hey 42 here if Hollywood is to be
believed almost all spies have a few
things in common they're good looking
they drive curiously expensive cars for
public sector workers they have access
to more high-tech gadgets than Marcus
Brownlee and most importantly of all
they have bollocks so big they could use
them as medicine balls and they don't
just mean that figuratively with a few
notable exceptions every Spy in
Hollywood history was male
the subject of today's video books most
of those Trends quite spectacularly
while she was famous for her looks as
far as I'm aware she didn't own a single
laser watch and she drove no luxurious
cars and whilst her metaphorical balls
were bigger than the Rock of Gibraltar
her literal ones were nowhere to be seen
and we always researched thoroughly on
this channel her name was matahari and
as well as being one of the most
notorious double agents the world of
Espionage has ever seen she also
happened to be the most famous erotic
dancer in history until lateral Man
debuted online in 2009.
after spying for both sides in the first
world war she would ultimately face a
friend's firing squad after her
duplicitous dealings led to the deaths
at 50 000 Allied soldiers
or did they history remembers matahari
as the ultimate Femme Fatale a
seductress Who Played with Fire and got
burnt well shot but you get the point
but some people believe she was nothing
more than a scapegoat used by the French
government to focus attention away from
the failings at the front as it turns
out the truth is much more interesting
matahari was born in the Netherlands in
1876 as Margarita Zella the daughter of
her successful hatmaker and the eldest
of four children she lived a comfortable
existence until the age of 13 when she
unexpectedly drew a ticket in the
lottery of life so bad a seagull would
refuse to [__] on it in the space of
just two years her father went bankrupt
her parents divorced and her mother died
she was sent to live with various
relatives and that 15 began studying to
be a kindergarten teacher
in later life she would become one of
the greatest sex symbols on the planet
but even in those days she was turning
heads faster than a chiropractor and she
was forced to leave the school after
having an affair with the head teacher
all in all Margarita's life wasn't
turning out quite the way she'd hoped so
she set about trying to change it and
the opportunity to do just that soon
showed up in the back pages of the local
paper
[Music]
Captain Rudolph MacLeod sounded like a
Star Trek reject but was in fact a
wealthy officer in the Dutch colonial
army stationed in Indonesia then known
as the Dutch East Indies and he was
looking for a wife Tinder not having
been invented yet he decided the best
way to try and find one was by placing
an advert in the paper whilst on leave
back home hoping some lucky lass would
swipe right across its broad sheets
Margarita promptly responded including
the one thing sure to land her the job a
photo of herself
the captain liked what he saw in her
19th century sext and after a long
romantic courtship that lasted a whole
six days the happy couple married in
Amsterdam before setting sail for the
East Indies but there were soon trouble
in Paradise because it turned out that
as well as being a wealthy and respected
army officer Rudolph was also a violent
alcoholic who kept a living lover
didn't put that in your ad did you
Rudolph
despite the fact that he was a raging
philandering drunk ass wipe the couple
had two children Norman and Louise but
eventually Rudolph's Behavior became too
much for margarita to bear and she left
him to live with another army officer
it was around this time to join the
local dance trip and took the stage name
of matahari meaning eye of the Dawn in
the local dialect she had no way of
knowing it then but the moniker would
soon be world famous
Margarita and Rudolph briefly reconciled
but things went from bad to absolutely
bloody horrific when their son Norman
passed away in unusual circumstances in
1899. the couple claimed one of the
servants poisoned him but most
historians believe Norman died from
syphilis he contracted from his parents
after the death of their son they
returned to Amsterdam but their marriage
which hadn't exactly been a modern
retelling of Romeo and Juliet to begin
with was officially over like the true
gentleman that he was Rudolph refused to
pay child support and just to make sure
history would remember him as a solid
gold bastard he took out an advert in
the local paper politely requesting that
the entire Community treat his wife like
an exile
yeah anyway despite him having the
paternal instincts of a vulture on day
old roadkill Louise decided to live with
her dad and for the second time in her
life Margarita found herself with
absolutely nothing
but once again she somehow found the
strength to reinvent herself only this
time the consequences would be even more
explosive
Paris in the early 1900s was one of the
most exciting cities in the world this
was the so-called bellepok the beautiful
era when if you had talent and ambition
anything was possible being prepared to
take your clothes off help too this was
the Heyday of the Moulin Rouge after all
[Music]
Margarita arrived in the city in 1903
and after a brief stint as a circus
horse rider she took to the stage as
matahari
her style of dance and overall aesthetic
Drew heavily on her time in Southeast
Asia and she constructed a backstory to
match no fool when it came to building
her brand rather than telling her
adoring fans that she came from a
middle-class family in the Netherlands
she concocted an elaborate Tale in which
she was an Indonesian Princess who'd
been learning the sacred art of Indian
dance since she was a child
little was known of the Dutch East
Indies at the time and it wasn't as if
people could just Google it this was so
long ago you couldn't even ask Jeeves
unless you had an actual Butler so all
of Paris swallowed mata's story like it
was a well-aged Bordeaux I'm sure the
fact that she was half naked whilst
telling it helped tremendously
along with her Newfound Fame Mata
acquired a string of rich and Powerful
lovers from masters of Industry to
high-ranking officers and politicians
for almost a decade she was the darling
of the press and not so polite Society
but by 1912 her career was on the Wane
and she was arguably better known for
the work she did lying down rather than
standing up she performed her last show
in 1915 before effortlessly
transitioning from high-class stripper
to even higher class escort traveling
throughout Europe alongside some of the
most powerful men of the day this kind
of sex Without Borders would have been
fine under normal circumstances but
circumstances in Europe were anything
but normal still not even the outbreak
of the first world war could derail
matahari's transcontinental Bona font
the Netherlands remains neutral during
the conflict and as a Dutch citizen she
could still go wherever she liked and
with whomever she pleased
in a break from her usual pattern of
sleeping with men older than a good
Stilton she began a passionate affair
with Captain Vadim maslov a Dashing
Young Russian pilot who was fighting
alongside the French in 1916 he was shot
down and so badly injured in the crash
that he lost sight in his left eye
he was taken to a hospital near the
Western Front and when matahari asked
permission to visit him she was told
that she could do so on one condition
the French wanted her to become a spy
to begin with that might sound like a
left field call she had absolutely zero
relevant qualifications and had spent
the previous 10 years shaking her bits
and tits in front of tens of thousands
of people then selling them to the
highest bidder not exactly covert
but when you think about it it was a
stroke of Genius here was a woman who
had extremely intimate access to
Europe's high and mighty many of whom
came from the military or Politics As
far as the friends were concerned she
was a guided missile who could be relied
upon to strike the heart of any
high-level Target in Europe provided
said Target had a penis and this was
1916 so that was basically all of them
and so matahari became a French
intelligent asset practicing what I'm
going to call horizontal diplomacy
she was thrown in right at the deep end
too her first Target was some bloke
called Crown Prince wilhel elderson of
Kaiser Wilhelm II emperor of Germany
Wilhelm Jr had seen matahari Dance
Before the War and the idea was that she
would catch him in a Honey Trap before
taking him somewhere private and
vigorously pumping him for information
if successful she will be paid 1 million
francs as the French believed Little
Willy was a senior General with access
to all kinds of secrets that could help
swing the war in their favor
[Music]
on the face of it this salacious scheme
made perfect sense the most famous
courses on in the world charms one of
Germany's military Titans into bed and
in between playing hide the bratwurst
finds out all she can to help La
Republic
unfortunately there were two major flaws
the first was that the prince was about
as far away from being a war hero as
matahari was from being a nun
the German propaganda machine had
painted him as a mighty warrior who was
key to the war effort
but in reality Little Willy was a big
dick he was a drinker and womanizer and
he spent more time scheming to depose
his own father than he ever did on
eliminating Germany's enemies still
matahari had bigger things to worry
about than her targets not having any
information worth stealing because not
long after the French enlisted her as a
sex spy she met the aptly named Carl
creamer German Consul in the Netherlands
he offered her 20 000 francs to become a
double agent and spy for Germany and she
promptly accepted
so as far as both sides are concerned
matahari was working for them
you don't need to be a genius to know
that like most threesomes someone was
going to get shafted
towards the end of 1916 matahari
traveled to Madrid where she seduced
major Arnold Keller German military
attache to Spain she managed to get some
information from him but nothing her
French handlers considered to be worth
the large sum of money they'd promised
her in January 1917 major callus sent a
series of communiques to Berlin
detailing the Stellar work of a German
spy code named agent h21 from his
description it would have been obvious
to anyone listening that 821 was
matahari and as it turned out people
were listening the French intercepted
the messages and decoding them proved
easy as they were in a code that had
long been broken
but here's the thing the Germans knew
that code had been broken so nobody
knows for sure why the messages were
sent in that code but it's widely
believed the Germans suspected matahari
was working for the French and they
deliberately lied about her being a
German spy in easily interceptable
Communications as a clever way of
eliminating her
if that was indeed their plan it worked
perfectly
on the 13th of February 1917 French
agents burst into matahari's hotel room
on the chandeliza she was arrested and
her luxurious surroundings replaced by a
rat infested jail cell in San Lazar
prison
her trial began on the 24th of July and
from the start there was only going to
be one verdict the prosecutor was
Captain Pierre bouchardon better known
as the grand Inquisitor for his shall we
say enthusiastic interrogation tactics
he didn't have a hard time convincing
the jury that matahari was a double
agent and born liar after all she'd
fabricated every iota of her life from
her background to her name he would have
had a harder job accusing a fish of
swimming the trial was also a complete
sham the French fabricated evidence
against her and her defense layer wasn't
even allowed to cross-examine the
Witnesses in desperation matahari
contacted the Dutch Embassy in Paris and
asked for help but they flatly refused
she even reached out to her great love
Captain maslov to see if he would
testify on her behalf but again
no dice
abandoned by everyone in her hour of
need she was found guilty and sentenced
to death
Just Before Dawn on the 15th of October
1917 she stepped out in front of a
friend's firing squad numerous Legends
have emerged about her final moments
some say she went to die dressed in an
immaculately tailored suit she'd had
commissioned for the occasion others
that she refused to blindfold so she
could look to soldiers in the eye as
they pulled their triggers apparently
she even blew them a kiss just before
they fight
[Music]
for years after her death matahari was a
symbol of sordid sexuality the
temperatures who got caught in a web of
her own lies and paid the ultimate price
but as with everything in her life the
truth is far fuzzier in 1917 things were
looking Bleak for France soldiers were
being slaughtered in vast numbers many
at the front were mutinying and the
already fragile economy was further
crippled by a wave of strikes matahari
became the perfect scapegoat for the
nation's woes a sort of seductive Eve in
the garden of French despair she was the
ideal fall girl a known personality that
the media could drool over and a
foreigner to boot two for the price of
one it was widely reported at the time
that she had confessed to being a German
spy but in reality she maintained her
innocence until the very end she did
admit to having taken money from Carl
creamer but here's the thing she only
met that guy in the first place in an
attempt to get close to the Crown Prince
taking the money and convincing the
Germans she was on their side would have
been a good way of doing that whatever
the truth one thing's for sure the case
against her was as flimsy as a wet
tissue in the years after the trial the
deputy prosecutor admitted that there
wasn't enough evidence to whip a cat let
alone have a woman shot it seems that
rather than the ultimate double agent
matahari might very well have been a
scapegoat or should that be a
sacrificial lamb who was punished most
of all for living life on her own terms
for a decade in the early 20th century
she was arguably the most desired woman
on planet Earth but after her execution
nobody wanted anything to do with her
except perhaps for the necrophiliacs
sorry none of her surviving family ever
came forward to claim her remains so
instead they were released for medical
research her embalmed body was kept at
the Museum of anatomy in Paris for 80
years before a routine inspection
uncovered something rather bizarre
someone had stolen her mummified head to
this day it has never been recovered
it seems that even in death something
about matahari was Simply Irresistible
thanks for watching foreign